[Music]
Kristen Wigg is joining the cast of
Wonder Woman ready to on Friday Wonder
Woman director patty Jenkins announced
that the Saturday Night Live alum will
have a big part in the highly
anticipated sequel Sweeting yes it's
true can't wait to finally work with one
of my favorites and so excited by what
we have planned
hashtag cheetah gal gadot who plays the
kick butt superhero they this is the
role of my dreams was also amped about
the casting choice tweeting quote I'm so
excited to welcome onboard Kristen this
is going to be wonderful the 44 year old
actress is set to play cheetah who
according to the DC comics was created
by dr. psycho and is one of Wonder
Woman's most persistent adversaries in
January Jenkins and Godot dish to ET
about what fans can expect from the
sequel which isn't scheduled to hit
theaters until sometime in 2019 so we're
actually making a totally different film
with a lot of the same similar like
things that we love but it's a it's its
own movie completely so it's not to
anything to us yeah to us it's an
entirely new adventure together
[Music]